olá gente boa tarde senhor que sonho
isso é apaixonante bom gente eu sou do
município de moju jô nasce uma
comunidade ribeirinha do ministério do
interior deste munícipe que mora até
hoje com a minha família e há seis anos
atrás quando eu ainda cursava o 7º ano
do ensino fundamental eu constatei que
ocorriam na minha comunidade dos
problemas bom e eu problematiza e duas
situações que ocorriam na minha
comunidade é e que com o tempo com a
minha implicância em trazer soluções
isso vem melhorando o primeiro problema
é o descarte do caroço do açaí
o açaí após passar pelo processo de
beneficiamento para obtenção do vinho o
que resta deste processo é o caroço
e é justamente este carol se é
descartado de maneira inadequada
pelas ruas da cidade ou descartado de
forma inadequada em cursos d'água
haja vista que o município não há
nenhuma política pública para o
aproveitamento desse resíduo
outro problema que observei na minha
comunidade é que a grande maioria das
famílias ribeirinhas da minha comunidade
consumiu água diretamente do rio sem que
essa água passa por nenhum tipo de
tratamento
haja vista que há grandes grandes a
grande parte das famílias ribeirinhas
que consomem essa água sobretudo as
crianças elas são assolados por doenças
de veiculação hídrica sendo as mais como
hipnose verminoses e se tornou famosa e
diarréia infecciosa em frente a esse
problema eu me posicionei frente a esse
problema eu quis encontrar uma solução
para os problemas para os problemas que
observei na minha comunidade e daí eu
nem sei a pesquisa pesquisando e em em
livros em artigos eu descobri que o
caroço do açaí
ele é rico em carbono e que me dá a
possibilidade de utilizá-lo como
material professor na produção de carvão
ativado
já com a idéia não é pronta eu me
questionei seria possível reaproveitar o
caroço do açaí que é exigido que é
considerado como lixo reaproveitável a
produção de carvão ativado para produzir
esse carvão e utilizá-lo eficientemente
notadamente de água sobretudo das
populações que marinhas da minha
comunidade e daí eu seria pesquisa e eu
procurei é pessoas professor
especialista da área para me orientar
mas ninguém quis me orientar ninguém
acreditou na minha ideia
eles diziam então vai conseguir ter um
aluno de escola pública a escola que
você estuda não tem laboratório como é
que você vai fazer uma coisa tão
grandiosa como essa com festa os
companheiros
confesso que me dá vontade de desistir
de voltar de parar ali porque todo
diesel não
mas como eu sou brasileiro e também
paraense mojuense do pé rachado
eu não desistir e nesse meio tempo eu
conheci uma professora uma guerreira que
hoje faz parte que coordena os os
trabalhos do clube de ciências de mosou
a professora raquel que há 24 anos vem
desenvolvendo um trabalho à frente do
clube decente mojo traçado uma luta
árdua para a construção do laboratório
próprio clube de ciências que faz parte
o grupo pedagógico de apoio
desenvolvimento científico eu conheci
ela me levou pra fazer parte do clube
decência de mossul
lá eu tive a honra de conhecer o
professor professor de química e física
professor waldemar rodrigues que passou
a ser meu orientador de pesquisa a e daí
a partir daí nós começamos a desenvolver
essa pesquisa dentro do clube de
ciências de moju mais o clube de
ciências de mossul infelizmente é a 24
anos tem passado como disse
anteriormente traçado uma luta para a
construção de um laboratório na bola um
laboratório digno para que a aluna ela
pública do município de moju possam
desenvolver suas pesquisas mas
infelizmente hoje essa luta ela só tem
acontecido não tem tido sucesso a e os
clubes decência eles nasceram só
reportando mas a história do corinthians
que faz é importante dizer de onde eu
vim do lugar onde o naf de onde eu
iniciei tudo que no caso é o clube
essência ele nasceu na dissertação de
mestrado da professora valendo a ufpa
com o intuito de democratizar o ensino
de ciências basicamente o ensino de
ciência de tornar esse ensino mais
acessível né e foi pensado essa reflexão
em um momento muito crítico da história
do brasil começa em 1989
a justamente tornar esse ensino
democrático e quanto senti dentro do
clube decência de mossul
pô agora tem alguém que vai olhar a
minha ideia que vai me orientar
é uma possibilidade de desenvolvimento
dessa idéia e eu comecei a leccionar
mas de que maneira eu vou desenvolver
essa idéia que o processo vai utilizar
para se produzir o carvão ativado
eu comecei a pesquisar e descobrir que
existe um dos processos pelos quais eu
posso produzir o carvão ativado é o
processo químico e o processo físico
gente como você vê esse sorriso no rosto
é da alegria de estar aqui hoje sabe
saiu é muito apaixonante tudo isso é
muito bom terminar jogo enquanto nós
vamos dar início à história e eu
descobri que existe um dos processos
pelos quais eu posso produzir carvão
ativado o processo químico e o processo
físico
eu disse então vou utilizar professor
waldemar utilizar o processo que
utilizando a substância química o
hidróxido de sódio como agente motivador
para produzir carvão ativado e dá início
a pesquisa
mas como eu disse anteriormente pra
vocês o clube de ciências de mossul
infelizmente ele não tem estrutura que
possa supor que pudesse suportar a parte
experimental da pesquisa
nós tivemos que recorrer ao clube
decência de abaetetuba que tem esse
laboratório e lá no laboratório do clube
ciência de abaetetuba
nós fizemos toda a produção do carvão
ativado quem envolveu três etapas
principais que a impregnação do caroço
do açaí né e com a substância ativa ante
o hidróxido de sódio processo de
pirólise simultâneo ao processo de
pirólise o processo de ativação
e estamos esse carvão no tratamento de
água de comunidades ribeirinhas e
enviamos para uma empresa na que faz
análises de água no município de anita e
lá porque também o clube sensação de um
dia vai ter tuba assim como com licença
de uso não tem suporte para que nós
pudéssemos fazer mais essa etapa da
pesquisa que a etapa experimental e nós
obtivemos obtivemos esse resultado
gente eu acho costumo dizer que esses
resultados foram nos últimos tempos foi
a maior alegria da minha vida aqui nós
temos três parâmetros físico-químicos e
microbiológicos a segunda mostra a
primeira mostra é referente à água
amostra de água que nós que não passou
por nenhum tipo de tratamento
percebam olha só o número que deus
conforme totais exorbitantes de 9,2 em
pronto para consumo humano
segundo o ministério da saúde diz que
tem que ser zero em cml de água esse
número de coliformes totais e o carvão
ativado produzido a partir do caroço da
saída pelo um processo alternativo
ele conseguiu reduzir a sério esse
número que é referente à 2ª mostra
e assim ele foi eficiente também para os
resultados do parâmetro turbidez ele
teve eficiência máxima ea maior alegria
ele foi mais eficiente de que o carvão
produzido pela indústria sendo que a
indústria ela produz para um processo
caro que utiliza altos e equipamentos
para produção de carvão
confesso para vocês quando eu observei
esses resultados professora
como eu disse foi a maior alegria da
minha vida até hoje me arrepio de nós
estávamos dentro de uma de uma dessa
linha do clube decência de de mossul
quando via e mail nós recebemos esses
resultados o olhar do professor diz o
professor é verdade isso é sério e essa
máxima é verdade professor ricardo me
questionando porque não queria acreditar
sabe de uma coisa que parecia um sonho
que ninguém acreditou que ninguém pôs pé
se tornou possível o carvão ativado que
o doido que o louco pensou se tornou
eficiente
se tornou realidade
aí você deve estar se perguntando mas
edvan como é que funciona esse e se esse
filtro que nada mais é do que um filtro
de carvão ativado um novo é um termo
técnico que se utiliza carvão ativo que
motivado assim queiram mas o porquê que
esse filtro edvan produzido com resíduo
que é o caroço do açaí porque ele sofreu
tanto definir porque ele desempenhou
essa eficiência porque ele foi eficiente
bom no momento da ativação que só
lembrando você que vacilam é um processo
é que diz que uma das propriedades
físicas desse carvão sofrer alteração no
caso a porosidade
então no momento da ativação nós
utilizamos o processo químico de
ativação utilizamos o hidróxido de sódio
no momento dessa articulação junto com o
processo de pirólise forma-se uma
estrutura porosa e aqui nós temos duas
médios para demonstrar isso pra vocês
que para que vocês possam entender a
primeira neve é um carvão não ativado
que não passou por nenhum processo de
ativação e a segunda greve é referente
ao carvão ativado a partir do karuá sei
que nós podemos perceber é que depois do
próprio depois de passar pelo processo
de ativação esse carvão aumentou a sua
estrutura porosa e é justamente por esta
rede interligada de poros é que o carvão
ele vem substituir a eficiência e esse
resultado foram maravilhosos muito bom
como eu disse anteriormente quando você
receber esses resultados
eu estava em uma salinha do clube de
ciências de moju e olhar para os
resultados não queria acreditar
eu lembro que a emoção era tão grande é
aquele momento era tão incrível que eu
saí correndo para o meio da rua
saí correndo dizendo que nem um doido se
já imaginava que fosse do outro e
chegaram à conclusão naquele momento eu
saí correndo dizendo conseguiram
conseguiam conseguir eu sou louco por
sonhar eu sou louco por acreditar
naquilo que a maioria não acreditou e
não dizer mais
eu dizia que não aceitava sonhos
perspectivas prontas acabadas
eu quero criar as minhas próprias idéias
a partir da minha realidade
eu quero criar os próprios sonhos
logo no início da pesquisa que comecei a
desenvolver essa pesquisa o que eu mais
queria era ser ouvido
eu queria que os professores
interessante pela minha ideia
a idéia do líbero lado hemosul
eu queria que os professores as pessoas
sempre esse prazer em orientar
desenvolver essa pesquisa
eu tentei isso por várias vezes não
conseguir passar por muitas e muitas
dificuldades mas em 2012
eu tive a oportunidade de participar de
eventos científicos pelo brasil com por
exemplo da feira brasileira de ciências
e engenharia em que eu fui premiado por
organizações como a unesco organizações
como o instituto de química da usp e em
eu tive o enorme prazer de ser um dos
vencedores na categoria do ensino médio
da 27ª edição do prêmio jovem cientista
que é um prêmio é organizado pelo
ministério de ciência e tecnologia
fundação roberto marinho eo conselho
nacional de desenvolvimento científico
a minha ideia valeu a pena né
tudo é considerado impossível até
acontecer eu nos seis anos em que
desenvolver essa idéia desde a concepção
inicial até os resultados finais
passei por muitas dificuldades muitas
pessoas não acreditaram na minha ideia
muitas pessoas chamaram de louco mas eu
não me deixava p
com essas opiniões eu não esqueci
tive uma idéia e acreditei nela tive
tenho meus sonhos e como louco os vendo
aliás chega a me questionar o que seria
do homem seus sonhos
talvez esse seja o maior diferencial de
nós mesmo pois quem sonha acredita no
improvável no impossível está além dos
demais
quem aqui não se lembra do sonho da
missionária dorothy stang de garantir
aos camponeses da amazônia o direito à
terra
pois é ela morreu por essa causa
quantas crianças sal quantas crianças
foram salvas por zilda arms o sonho da
pastoral da criança salvou milhares de
crianças não só da fome mas também do
afeto e tantas outras que pessoas todas
as outras pessoas que fizeram da sua
vida à luta por uma causa
o mundo meus queridos mundo o mundo
sente falta do que nós temos a oferecer
o mundo sente falta do que tu pensas a
mostrar o mundo sente falta dessa ideia
que está engavetada na tua cabeça eo
coração e que pelos problemas diários
você não luta ela
eu venho aqui pra te embora já tira
essas idéias na cabeça
ponha ela em prática o dívida transforma
e vindas
como eu disse o mundo sente falta da
presença de cada um aqui o mundo sente
fato o que você tem a oferecer
eu quando ganhou o prêmio jovem
cientista
cientista do mixto em 2013
houve muitas pessoas falarem dizerem
apesar dele ser ribeirinho
apesar de ser de escola pública apesar
de ele ser negro apesar dele ser é do
interior da amazônia às margens do rio
sul ele conseguiu ele venceu o prêmio
jovem cientista
eu discordo de tudo isso
jamais eu consigo imaginar a minha
história a minha trajetória diz
associada à minha identidade de quem eu
sou
se eu não tivesse na comunidade que
estou em que vivo eu jamais de nenhuma
forma eu teria identificado o descarte
do caroço do açaí como um problema
ambiental
eu jamais teria identificado o consumo
de água de maneira inadequada
realizado com ribeirinhos diretamente do
rio como um problema além do social mas
também com um problema de saúde pública
eu jamais teria passado por experiências
tão incríveis tão incríveis como por
exemplo eu não estaria aqui hoje
palestrando tds
sem palavras o mundo ele precisa de ti
são por essas pessoas só para aqueles
que sofrem santos pelos meus vizinhos e
tantas outras populações ribeirinhas que
povoa as margens do rio mimoso não só do
rio moju agitando os outros rios que
marge que tomam conta da região
amazônica por essa população que o luto
é por essa população que acordo todos os
dias e saio daqui tinetti onde eu moro e
vou por laboratório e vou para a
universidade é para encontrar soluções
para essas pessoas
proporcionar água ribeirinha à água de
boa qualidade para os ribeirinhos da
amazônia este continuará sendo meu
desafio agora me quer agora eu te quer
show no qual é o teu desafio após acabar
o pibex quanto o desafio para melhorar o
mundo pense reflita o mundo precisa de
nós sobretudo as pessoas que estão ao
nosso lado
obrigado